so hello everybody i'm very happy to be
here with two more v's many of you have
seen his work you've heard his uh music
uh two more v's has made many uh
um
many fusion of music with uh audio clips
and part of that has been going through
some of my talks and recently he went
through one of my first public talks
which was called pentecost for the
zombie apocalypse it was given at an oca
at an orthodox church
meeting with all these priests and the
bishop was there as well
and it was it was a moment that was very
unnerving to me because it was the first
time that i was talking to all these
bishops so i took a lot of time to
prepare i really wrote it down and i
memorized it and re-memorized it and and
i know that uh that marvin is is his
actual name uh marvin noticed that that
he was very prepared and so i think he
kind of grabbed on that and thought it
would be a good idea to bring it all
together and to make almost like a
musical out of my out of my uh on my
talk so i was really impressed with what
he did and i'm definitely looking
forward to talking to him about it and
you know what the choices that he made
and the decisions that he brought about
in this in this uh in this musical
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so marvin it's really good we've met
before on on not in person but in zoom
so it's good to talk to you again uh i'm
really looking forward to hearing about
about
how what your decisions were maybe you
can start and tell us what it is that
made you want to do this because it was
a massive project
right um
so
generally what what what made me go into
this kind of music this we call it
flo-fi
akira the dawn for example who also made
a song with your co calls it meaning
wave but um is is that
and you talk about that in your talk too
is that there is this hunger for meaning
and i feel that in myself and i see that
also in the world and in my friends
um
and
it it seems like it's so
most of the music and entertainment
culture in general is is meaningless
there's nothing that you can grab onto
it's nothing that you can let's say say
use to to also learn about the world and
learn how to how to act in it
and
i i
felt the
the the strong urge to
kind of participate in in changing that
especially after i found out about what
akira is doing and after i worked with
him for for a bunch of like i think six
months or something like that
um
and i started with with petersons with
jordan peterson's uh works because
that's also how i got into all of this
in in general like his interview with
kathy newman of course and uh then his
biblical lectures which also brought me
on the way towards the church
um
and then i was talking to
jacob and lisa
who both
loosely work with you on your channel i
think jacob's a moderator lisa manages
the clips channel right
yeah exactly and
uh
i think it was lisa who mentioned the
pentecost talk to me and said it's it's
it's really it's standing out from from
everything else that you've done
and so i gave it a listen and i i
instantly heard what she's what she said
and you mentioned it too that you
prepared it a little so it's it's it's
already a little segmented and it's
already a little like like like poetry
uh i think i would say and that that
also made it really easy so i just i i
listened to it and then i cut it up into
into the different pieces and then i
said okay let's see uh
how much how how far we get with this
uh you've been working on this for like
a year and a half maybe like it's been a
while yeah about i think i started
cutting it up uh in in maybe march last
year or something something like that
and
then i but but then i focused on a a
uh
album i wanted to do from from
peterson's talk um who dares say he
believes in god because i thought
to me personally personally it was a
a preparation for going into pentecost
and the icons themselves what you talk
about so i thought it would be better to
release that first but we i had some
problems contacting jordan again after
he gave me his initial okay obviously i
think it's uh yeah
and and so
then then i just i just uh thought okay
then i'll focus on the pentecost album
because i i had the preparation that i
needed from the album so uh then i then
i could get get into your stuff
yeah and you put it out on pentecost it
came out on pentecost day which was
which is a nice little uh nice little
move on your part to have that
yeah right right uh i initially wanted
to get it out on on halloween last year
when we did the live stream but well it
didn't didn't quite work out but but
that's good because then i had the time
to you know finish the songs properly
and and and all of that and then yeah
i'm
i'm very i'm very proud of of what what
came out of it and also surprised
that it worked out so well
so i'm going to surprise you with a
question
so before we go into some of the songs
on the clips if you can resume the talk
like because i guess you've listened to
it so many times now like if you can
resume the talk into into a short into a
short sentence or short statement what
would you say that the talk is about
sorry to put you on the spot there no no
no problem no problem i would say um
christ is here for everyone
and and and without exception for
everyone everyone can come to him i
think that's that's the message and
that's definitely the message that i got
from it
and uh yeah i get a little emotional
thinking about that to be honest because
your your whole emphasis on saint
christopher for example like the monster
that wasn't able to pray or fast or
abstain from anything
in the end being able to carry christ
across the river and to join the church
and to become the same that's so that's
it's so intensely moving
because i also i wasn't i wasn't
in a very good place let's say uh
for for a long time and also still still
not really when i when i um
yeah when i when i started
engaging with your content
uh you know drug use and all of that
like a modern world stuff
um
and i i didn't i didn't think that there
would be any place for me in the church
and so there was also no no no real
motivations why would i change anything
really because how how would i fit into
that and
yeah but but that i mean i was wrong
with that and then and your your talk
show showed me and i mean now i am uh
part of the orthodox church
and i'm i'm even considering becoming a
priest that's uh oh my goodness i didn't
know that well we've got the beard
already so yeah you got that going yeah
that's exactly what my priest said to he
said you've got the beard so you're
you're right that's amazing oh goodbye
the congratulations how when would you
when would you received in the church i
don't i don't remember when that
happened it was in uh i think march 13
so so it's like
three to four four four months now
okay
and yeah yeah that was and that was
a big chunk of that is
because of you and your content for sure
so so thank you very much on
on this on this note for for a second
yeah
well glory to god that you that you that
you came that you came through the
threshold so i'm happy to hear that
right
yeah so i think that's the that's the
sentence that i would bring a bring
bring it down to it's like crisis there
for everyone and everyone can join and
everyone can be saved
yeah
that's awesome
so you prepared some of the songs or
some of the clips from some of the songs
that we can kind of listen to a little
bit and then we can talk about so go
ahead set it up and and we'll we'll
we'll go in there
awesome we'll do
so we live in a time
of monsters
i announce this to you but i think
all of you already know that
we only need to glance at popular
culture to realize this
at the narrative level of our culture
and our stories
we've become obsessed with monsters
with the strange
alien the marginal
with the glorification of the exception
things that don't fit
most of us here probably grew up with
sesame street where we were told that
monsters are our friends
and it's no longer in fiction by now
the monsters
[Music]
have left the dark spaces under our beds
they have left our nightmares to come
out into the open
[Music]
at a social level we can feel and see
all around us the growing polarization
the acceleration of what we can only
call the
the breakdown
the decomposition of culture a
progressive dissipation of the center
which rallies us as a society
right so that was yeah the clip from the
first song monsters and the second
coming i think this one
came came about a little later in in in
the whole process
except for the the intro which when when
you listen to the album you you'll see
that there's like a minute of of
introduction to that song which this is
just weird sounds like like ufo sounds
and like ominous uh robotic breathing
and stuff like that which then
culminates in and
the drums you know uh getting getting
into it just just to make it a little
eerie and set the tone
yeah there's something
there's definitely something even in the
way that you kind of parse out
you modify the the the rhythm you know
that there's this
this kind of
slow there's this kind of slow move it
makes reminds you of some of the
like some of the music that i was
listening to in the in the late 90s this
kind of this kind of intense slow
movement you know this this this guitar
but is how can i say this kind of
bringing you bringing you somewhere but
in in this intense slow manner and so
that's what i was getting from that when
i listened to the first time
nice yeah that's also what i was trying
to try to uh cause the listener to feel
let's say when i was doing that i like
that when it's when it's it is slow but
it's it's uh
you know this this this kind of
unstoppable even even though it's slow
like it's
going to going to go forward anyway
yeah that's a good that's a good image
like uh this this kind of slow but
unstoppable movement that's coming
towards you definitely that's a good way
to describe it
um and so that was it's funny because
when i listened to myself uh i can hear
because i was i was i had i was reading
and i had memorized at the same time and
so i can hear the mistakes that i make
like just in terms of grammar i can make
a few gram grammatical mistakes which is
totally fine
this is where people realize sometimes
that i'm not a native english speaker
even though people think i am i make
these strange grammatical mistakes and
the way i'm speaking sorry that that's
what i'm hearing it's hard for me not to
hear that when i'm listening to it no i
understand it i think if it were the
other way around i would notice that too
um
because i'm also not a native speaker
like my native native native language is
german
but
it's there are even some
a few moments uh where because you made
a grammatical mistake that that's what
made it possible to have it aligned with
the rhythm of the song so i'm just i'm
happy about that i think you guys like i
was actually what i was actually doing
was changing the grammar to you know to
fill the beat that's what i was doing
yeah it was all it was always all
deliberate from the beginning
um
so so yeah so so and so that's the first
song uh and that's really just my kind
of my introduction talking about
monsters and uh
just kind of getting people because i
was dealing with a lot of people at that
time if you have to think that this was
like in 2017
i think right so we were dealing with
people even i think it was the early
late 2016 maybe dealing with people that
had never heard
my content at all and so i was going in
cold for most of the people in the
audience
and trying to kind of
paint a general image of something that
paint a general image of something that
was maybe they had never ever thought
about and so so it was yeah it was
really nerve-wracking uh so trying to
get little images of sesame street and
these monsters that kind of pervade our
culture to get people to realize
something they never realize even though
it's so obvious once you've seen it
write it becomes so obvious but a lot of
people don't don't see it they they just
live imbibe their culture so yeah even
even our buses they have these little
machines where you check in your your
ticket and they they are called ticket
monsters now and they are also you know
painted in that way that that it's like
a little monster that you have to feed
like it's it's it's literally it's
everywhere
yeah exactly well once you start to see
you start to see the the let's say the
pattern of what's going on then then
it's hard to turn back you just it just
you just notice that it's and it's
increasing too it's just the the things
like the things that i talked about in
20 it's funny because this year if kobit
permits who knows but in in the fall i'm
i was asked to come talk to the same
group so the same oca it's the diocese
of the south and they have their their
kind of meeting of all the priests and
the bishop together so they asked me to
go speak at their their assembly again
and it's just so funny because
everything i said which was in almost
was there but now it's like times it's
times 10 now um
and so i don't know how i'm gonna deal
with that in terms of doing this a talk
again to all these priests as i i've
been thinking about it like almost
obsessively okay so how am i going to
outdo myself now with that talk that i
did four years ago
that is i'm looking forward to that then
then we'll have a part two
have a part two of the musical indeed
right that's hilarious how did how did
they how did they react to it because
for me it was easy to accept all of that
because i was on the outside and i was
kind of a monster so so i liked hearing
that but people who are
you know on the inside might not
what was the reaction
i would say at least my my impression of
what happened was extremely positive
like it was it was
i would say
that at some point i felt like i had the
the audience kind of hypnotized i don't
know what else how else to describe it
you know at first i was kind of looking
out and i was seeing puzzled faces
and then as the talk
went on all of a sudden i could see
people get into the groove of what i was
saying
um
and uh and then by the end of the talk i
think there was really like a buzz i
don't know how to explain it like a buzz
in the audience and so i really it was
overwhelmingly positive i would say in
general
my the reaction that i've had from my
hierarchy has been overwhelmingly
positive obviously i've been worried
about that because i'm talking about
things in a way that
are a little surprising to some and
maybe are not from the same angle
and so i was i was always worried that
people wouldn't understand what my
purpose was or what i was getting to but
i haven't felt that i've really been
supported by my own bishop and then by
you know just by the the hierarchy in
general so that's been that's been
wonderful
yeah that's that's awesome to hear also
i'm i mean i'm not i'm not completely
surprised because the orthodox church is
much more embedded in in all of this
mysterious stuff let's say uh than than
well the different the other churches um
but but yeah that's that's that's really
great to hear and also reassuring let's
say
yeah and i do i do still get some
pushback because of the icon of saint
christopher and i sympathize with that i
totally understand that some priests are
not happy that i am
making images of that icon or just
talking about it or you know posting
about it because it was condemned in a
russian late russian council in a
council that is uh
under peter the under peter the great
peter the first
um and it's but the most interesting
thing about that is the reason why they
are angry about me
promoting the icon
is actually the reason why i'm doing it
because they think that they think that
i am demonizing the other that i am that
i am you know kind of
portraying this idea of the alien as a
monster and all of that and i keep
trying and i keep trying to help them
understand that
it's a saint
it's like it's an icon of a saint and
the people that love that icon that i've
encountered are people who feel like
that monster
right it's not it's not it's not like
i'm saying all these evil monsters is
that that image is actually calling
people who feel in them an aspect of of
marginality or misunderst of being
misunderstood of being they identify
with that
and that's that's like the weirdest
thing
uh for people to understand that that
that you know some people really do we
all to a certain extent have that in us
you know like an aspect of the gargoyle
in us but i think some people in some
more
some people in particular
have feel more that way and so i think
that that icon is playing the opposite
role of what he thinks it is he thinks
it's pushing people away but i think
it's actually it's actually attracting
people that are the weird and the and
the strange because it's it's still an
icon of a saint and they can they can
identify with the story of not being
able to fully fit in but then
nonetheless having a place and having a
role to play in that in that story so so
it's a funny it's a funny situation
but i still i sympathize with people who
are annoyed with me that's like the
biggest thing that i've gotten in terms
of pushback has been about about the
icon of saint christopher that's
interesting i thought that if you were
to get pushback i thought it would be
because um well they themselves wouldn't
like the icon like i i don't i don't
like to see this as part of part of the
tradition i thought that would be the
problem but uh yeah i get that too well
that's why they don't like it because
it's it's suggesting
it's because it's talking about the
stranger as a as like almost like as a
monster and you know and also because
they don't like the idea of dehumanizing
you know this idea of kind of
dehumanizing people which is right
they're totally right it's like they're
completely right but that's the that's
the whole mystery of this encounter with
the strange and how we are able to then
ultimately find ways to to to bridge you
know the that's what a saint christopher
ends up being is a bridge from the
inside to the outside so it does always
have a strangeness to it so yeah
which is also um
i mean also
mystery itself is is like part of part
of i've been talking about that to a
friend of mine mystery itself is kind of
part of of being and part of the pattern
it's not not like mystery is something
that's only not revealed it's like
mystery itself is as is a
uh
as a stone that fits into the wall that
we
or something like that you i i think you
get what i mean yeah exactly that that
there is an aspect of reality which is
not
properly represented and because of that
it appears to us sometimes in in these
in these types of strange forms let's
say you know and so on the edge of the
world you encounter a dog-headed man but
then at the edge of the holy of holies
you encounter a beast with four wings
it's like
humans with wings i know it i know you
think it's it's not as weird to have a
human with wings but it's still weird
like just because we're used to it
doesn't mean it's not weird like a man
with a headed with a dog-headed face
it's like those are those are weird
images too they're images that are
pointing to something like you said
which is not fully graspable in our
category so right i mean just think of
of the i think the ophanim like this
these wheels within wheels which have
like with eyes on them
like what what is that
you know
if yeah if if that if that isn't weird
so so yeah i i i get what you mean it's
it's it's yeah we're just used to the
image of people with wings i would say
that's just it's more normal to us
because we see it more often yeah we see
more often and we think that it's that
it's similar but it's like a lot of the
angels are are warriors too just like
saying christopher they they're just
they're just it's almost like their
reflection
saint christopher stands on the edge of
the world and the the angels stand
between us and god they stand on the
edge but the on the other edge right the
edge the bridge between the higher and
the lower uh and so they both appear as
warriors they both appear as a form of
hybrid um but it also makes sense that
their hybridity is different you know
that they would have something like the
head of a human
and then the the body or the wings of a
bird whereas on the other edge which is
the very edge of the world then you
would have something like the head of an
animal on the body of a of a human it's
almost like the the reverse but it's
also showing the place in the hierarchy
in terms of of strangeness
yeah right right i hadn't even noticed
that yet this this uh turning it around
but yeah you're right okay yeah we could
we could get into the next clip yeah go
for it as the narrative fabric
of our world begins to fill in
quantities that are barely possible to
believe
with images of the monstrous as we feel
the world being torn apart by
fragmentation
and conflict
we are simultaneously as individuals
being constantly assaulted
by images
images with the purpose
of awakening our own desires
we've come to the point where we
most of us so many of us have been
accustomed to the constant exposure to
the stranger and stranger fringe
of desire
whilst being enticed
by the siren song to indulge
to give into the
to waves into the mire
those two things the edge and the end
they represent the same structure
they're the same thing
in our stories
those two things the edge and the end
they represent the same structure
so even
when he is a zombie
man is a microcosm
yeah i don't know if you notice
but the
the the the image that i used is kind of
it's not explicit but but you get what
it what it kind of looks like right yeah
i thought i thought it was funny i was i
was walking um walking outside of my
outside of my house and just saw it i
thought yeah we can use that we can use
that
and so i really i really like i like
this one a lot just because also there's
more surprise in the way that you played
with the words and everything
uh and and listening to it really
really made me remember what some of the
things that i was able to do because it
was so written it was i was able to to
to constantly
move between the analogy
uh you know between the desire
you know the monsters the edge all of
this trying to kind of play between
these different levels to help people
see
what i was talking about you know like
allude to desire and then to siren songs
and to to these monsters that are on the
edge but that are participate in your
your desires and so i was like i was
like yeah yeah i was trying to do that i
remember now
and it worked out very well you it like
to now to me it seems like you you were
starting different different threads in
the beginning and then bringing them
more and more together and the more you
progress the more you so oh yeah he
talked about that like two minutes
earlier and then and then it's it's it's
referencing ref referencing uh back and
forth and that's uh
it it also makes you have this these
these aha moments where where you when
you get the connection between the the
different levels of symbolism let's say
yeah that's that's always been what i've
been trying to do all the time is to try
to surprise people by these connections
that they don't expect and that kind of
comes together
but you know the with the way that you
described it makes sense
also make sense of the puzzlement the
puzzled look that i was getting at the
beginning
right it's like where is he going where
is he going because it that's that's
exactly what you said it's like i'm kind
of pulling on these threads and i'm i'm
pulling them together but you can't see
yet you know what the with the image is
and then slowly it kind of builds up
towards uh towards with something that
now you're like okay okay this is what
is going on or this is what is happening
so uh yeah so that makes a lot of sense
yeah yeah um
it's it's
yeah it's it's it's very very
interesting also very helpful the whole
notion of um
of the of the different levels when you
when you start to recognize oh this is
actually that and that's also this and
this and this
this is uh kind of what made it
um
impossible for me to to push away chris
the christian story uh christian pattern
anymore because you know at first you're
like oh yeah yeah that makes sense okay
cool but but all these other things also
make sense but when you see how how how
how close let's say it is like there's
no it's it's it's all encompassing
um wherever i look when i when i think
about it hard enough or when i when i
read the right things um then i then i
then i get the the connection between
the between the things and i never had
that with any of my my adopted
uh world views let's say it was you know
i was uh engaged in all this new ag
stuff and and maybe a little buddhism
here a little hinduism there and oh yeah
that sounds nice yeah yeah um
yes and but but it all it all stops
making sense when you stop when you when
you start thinking about it really hard
and try to compare and and and all of
that but that's not the case yeah and
mostly the mostly the layering is the
issue is is one of the problems of the
kind of new age
movement or the
the new age direction is how it is so
individualistic it ends up being in very
individualistic and there isn't the
natural
kind of hierarchy of patterns that lay
themselves on top of each other and then
create this web that you can live in and
so it either ends up being completely
idiosyncratic like uh you know everybody
who takes like you said a little bit of
this a little bit of that they put it in
a pot and then they they have this
breathing technique and this yoga
practice and you know this and that and
they have a singing bowl or whatever and
they burn us this this this uh you know
they'll burn a certain amount of incense
or whatever
but it's all kind of this convoluted
thing uh so it ends up being
idiosyncratic or it's like a guru
and like a bunch of devotees and then
it's it's like this this weird little
tyranny that usually doesn't last like
it ends up breaking down because it's it
doesn't it doesn't participate in these
bigger bigger uh stories um and so and
it's also it's even sometimes the way
that we understand even christianity
people want to represent it as a
revolutionary thing
but we need to re remember that if you
read in scripture it says that the
disciples went to the synagogue
every day
right until they were chased out of the
synagogue the disciples didn't think
they were starting something new they
really thought like they were just part
like revealing or kind of manifesting
something which was already there uh but
they were participating in its
revelation um and so that's also that's
important to understand
and that's why like you said that's why
christianity ends up once you take it
seriously and you realize that it it it
connects
different levels of reality together you
understand why it why it's held the west
white held the west together for for
millennia so
yes the only thing it's uh also like
especially this aspect is something that
after jordan talked about it obviously
but something that i i so much love
about nietzsche and and and his writing
is because he he understood that he he
understood that that's like if you take
god out of the equation then everything
else falls apart too uh it's it's
impossible to to remain like this what's
it like this humanist idea that you you
can just be a good human being without
having any basis for it yeah that works
as long as it's not tested but yeah and
as long as you try as long as you take
for granted that being good me basically
comes from christianity because i love
it when people say that you can be good
and be an atheist i'm like no you don't
understand it's not even whether you can
be good and be an atheist it's that what
is the ground for which from which you
gather the good like even the good
itself
you know it's so you so you're usually
they're saying something like i can be
an atheist and still
basically follow christian values with a
few modifications it's like
it doesn't work but it works for a while
like you said and then it then it peters
out and it kind of runs out of steam and
becomes
idiosyncratic or tyrannical so yeah i
mean what's what's the use why not do
the things that you know you shouldn't
do but but there's no
there's no moral basis for why you
shouldn't do it it's just yeah
convenience let's say yeah convenience
or power like some kind of state
enforcement that you know those two
sides end up getting stronger
right
uh yeah so so that's that's that's
that's very interesting for sure
um yeah i would i would play the next
clip go for it awesome
the garments of skin is seen by the
church fathers
[Music]
as all that is added to our nature
in the world of the fall the layers of
society of technology those are the flip
side and in a way they're of the same
nature as our weakness
and the passions which come
from the world of death
saint gregory of nisa tells us that the
hairs on our body
are a symbol of death
they're without feeling dead
and appear as our spatial extremities
the very limits of our garments of skin
just as death appears as our temporal
extremity
of this earthly life
of this earthly life
the giants in the bible
those that appeared before the flood
with a sign of confusion and mixture
wrapped in inappropriate sexual desire
wrapped in inappropriate sexual desires
in the tradition of enoch
they're seen as the origin of technology
and magic
they were known to create hybrids
they were full of excess prevailing in
conflict until absolute chaos could no
longer be held at bay and the world was
undone in the waters
yeah
what interested me in that is that there
are so many there's like
like three or four melodies in that
little part like you keep switching from
like so from from different even not
just melee but just like the actual
tone or the the the feeling that's in
the music so it's like the first is this
kind of almost like heavy metal
heavy uh guitar and then it moves into
something which is almost like it's
almost light or it's lighter you know
and then you so i don't know i i'm
curious to know like what how what's
your decision-making process when you're
kind of bringing this together
um
i i i don't i i don't know how how
common that is but when i
in in general but but especially in
music when i when i work on music i
experience it as a as a almost visible
landscape that that maps that kind of
kind of maps on on the landscape that i
see with my eyes and it's it's like when
i when i go through um
different melodies it's it's like going
through let's say an alley where where
it's like all a little it's it's it's
dark there and and and maybe a little
little wet on the floor or something and
and then i then i get into more open
spaces and i i and i kind of i even i
see
the the let's say the buildings or the
plants or whatever and the colors and
that's that's how i try to navigate
through that is when i i play a note uh
or a melody or something and then then i
see yeah yeah that fits but if that it
needs a window there or
something like like like that let's say
and um with
for example the when you when you talk
about the giants and their
inappropriate sexual desire
like i
i had a the the the sentence wrapped in
an appropriate sexual desire that that
um
caused caused me to feel something
specific and then i i got my guitar and
i tried to
try to translate that let's say
um i i feel like the the riff that i
play not the heavy metal stuff but the
the the palm muted stuff that's in the
in the lighter verse
it sounds kind of sticky to me yeah yeah
yeah
yeah interesting yeah kind of kind of
yeah that's a good that's a good way of
understanding it that makes sense
interesting so you listen to the music
you listen to the words and then
depending on where the music where the
words seem to kind of bring you into a
different space then you'll apply like a
different melody to that to that that's
what i'm getting yeah yeah uh definitely
um i mean it's not that i always listen
to the bit first and then make a start
making music for it i oftentimes have a
rough beat where i feel like yeah yeah
that's that's kind of where where where
jonathan's moving here is that
this is the same space so i bring it
together and then i adjust it and i
adjust your speech and i adjust the
music again
uh but yeah that's that's kind of my my
way of navigating through through that
and just out of like i'm just curious to
know
how like how long does it take to put
together a song like this
it depends i mean there are some
songs that i had to work on for for
like a year even to to get to where i
wanted to but there are others where
where it takes a few weeks to
and maybe like there are even ones that
i that i have almost done in two days uh
but then then it's it's mix and
mastering is is coming and then maybe
i'm adjusting it uh to to sound more a
little bit more like the other song so
it fits together uh but yeah that it
really depends that's it's from from two
interesting definitely
and so what is it that fascinated you
with this because you said you were kind
of
the idea of the garments of skin because
it's it's definitely one of the most
important
i mean for me it's one of the most
important images i use to help people
understand the modern world let's say
and understand technology and understand
this kind of world of
this world of layers so i'm just curious
about what like what is it about that
idea that that kind of resonated with
you
on on one hand it's it's again it's
showing the symbolism that's it's
everywhere like man is a microcosm and
and it showed me that so that that
yeah made it made it even more more
apparent how all encompassing
these patterns are and um
also
how this is
i would
i would say that the
the
that it's all uh a
even even musical instruments that that
we use and also the skin that we have
and and all all that we do all the
technologies that we have a consequence
of the fall like i wasn't i wasn't i was
never aware of how
that's because we're where we are like i
thought yeah yeah we fell that's also a
thing that happened but it's that's the
reason for history at all and and and so
that's yeah that was so strange to to
realize
yeah but and it's interesting to see how
in scripture once you understand that
you can notice how
god is constantly
recapturing
let's say the space of the fall and kind
of transforming
the the fall into
into something else you know and so
making
making technology uh you know making
singing into something which is directed
towards him making
architecture you know into something
which is also a temple and directed
towards him so this kind of movement
from all these things that are developed
by the lineage of cain in the fall then
end up being kind of turned back towards
towards god of course and then the
ultimate image is the new jerusalem in
the end of this this kind of filling up
of the world with a city but that a city
that is
shining this glorious city which is this
double inversion that you will also talk
about later and right right yeah
which yeah that's
i always have to laugh when i think
about that because it's so
i don't even know uh no no worry to
describe it it's it's it's so funny
because i i would would have thought
that there's no double inversion that
that's just things are wrong and then
you then then they are set right and
that seems so authoritative and
and so but but it's more like
i mean like like saint christopher
tricking
the devil
into into revealing christ to him like
and and
this is funny i can't i cannot not laugh
at that
yeah especially that story and then then
ultimately like the ultimate irony of
the story of saint christopher
is that he wants because you have to
always remember that he wants to serve
the strongest person
that's what he wants and so he goes out
and he serves these different characters
that finally kind of reveal christ to
him
but he still doesn't get it right so he
he's there on the side of the river and
then he ends up
serving the weakest person
right so this child his little baby
comes up to him and so he he he
he serves the weakest person but then
it's actually it's actually christ
tricking
saint christopher into serving him
right that's what's going on it's like
he's like just carry me across the water
and then as he's carrying him across the
water he's realizing what's going on and
it's like okay this is not what i
thought it was going to be this is not
what i thought and then and then finally
once he reaches to the other side then
he realizes that he
the thing that he wanted from the
beginning which was to serve
the strongest man or the the the highest
king he ended up doing it without even
realizing that he was doing it like it's
part of also
he was kind of he was kind of saved
despite himself you could say you know
so it's a it's really an amazing it's
such an amazing uh like every time you
look at it you end up seeing how there's
a lot of other stuff going on in that
story that maybe you didn't notice at
the outset yeah it's very often like
this this idea that you have to let go
of something when you're when you're
clinging too much to it let's say but
then you like not not always but but
sometimes it god just gives it to you
anyway after you let go of it after you
you know start your your detachment to
it let's say
exactly like when you're too attached to
something it makes you lose it and then
if you
if you if you're willing to be detached
from it you find it again in very
surprising ways you know sometimes not
in the way you expect it but it
definitely comes back to you
yeah
i mean that's that's even something that
you you can you can observe in human
relationships when you when you're
clinging to a person let's say a friend
or girlfriend or or something like that
and
it's yeah that's it's very very very
interesting
yeah i can i can play the next clip oh
no before that um the uh
the
i don't i don't know if that worked
maybe tell me when i when i made the the
music for desire i that was the last
song that i made for for the album um
and i wanted to do like i wanted to have
a sexy song let's say you know where
it's like did that work out
well i don't i do because the problem is
that i don't remember the names of the
it's it's not the last one we heard but
that one before where you say like the
things the etch and the end represent
the same structure and all that
i don't know if i would have okay so i
wouldn't know if i would have recognized
it that way maybe it's also because i
don't expect it to be that and so i'm
not sure i would recognize it that way
sorry yeah no problem no problem
um yeah i'll i'll play the i'll play oh
i think because of the funky bass
as the narrative fabric
of our world begins to fill in
quantities that are barely possible to
believe
right with images yeah you're right
you're right i did it's funny because
when you played it this time i did
notice the bass and i'm like he's got
this like funky bass to go in in there
and so but i didn't connect it which is
obviously which makes sense because
that's also what funk was always about
kind of like that you know uh
what's his name barry white or whatever
with like the the this kind of low bass
and so no you're right now that you say
it and i remember that it's kind of low
base coming in i'm like yeah okay i get
it i get it
oh nice yeah thank you awesome
okay okay
the next one is um
the the seventh song the ultimate
unexpected it's very short and i made it
so short because i want people to want
to listen to it twice
the monster is both encountered with the
surprise of the future
as we move forward
in time
so to encounter the unexpected
the monster is also the encounter with
the surprise of the edge
as the church expands to the dark
corners of the world but also the dark
corners of our own lives
as the spirit of god transforms us
for most of us there will always be
foreign elements monsters hiding
in our garments of skin
so here in pentecost this monster is
represented as not yet in the church
in the church
[Music]
but as part of the potential into which
the church can grow
as part of that which can hear the
gospel in its language
as part of the potential into which the
church can grow
as part of that which can hear the
gospel
in its language
i really like that one uh i think it's
probably one of the most musical ones
that has that has more more melody and
the idea of kind of singing over
my voice as i'm saying things i think it
really is effective it really does
something and it also it almost makes
you hear the mu the melody in my own
voice
as i'm talking and you can hear the
melody being sung behind it you know it
kind of fuses together with my with my
voice i really think it's probably one
of the best ones in terms of the terms
of the song element of it
yeah i think it was also i gotta say the
maybe the most fun to record at least
the singing stuff because it yeah it
moves very nicely and also uh you
mentioned it yourself like uh that you
have an inherit
maybe everyone but you especially have
an inherent um melody in in the way that
you talk and it
uh it
thank you it makes it rather
easy to do this kind of stuff
yeah that's funny i don't realize i
wonder like i wonder if if i have the
same melody in french as i do in english
i'd be curious to know like if the
language you speak will affect the way
like the the the tonality that you use
i'm one i don't know i have no idea i
might i i mean i don't i don't i don't
really speak french like only a few
sentences even though i i had it four
years in school i just i wasn't very
good at it
well what about you between english and
german do you feel like it's a different
melody in terms of the
the sounds that it's bringing about
it's more melodious in
in english than in german i would i
would say uh that's that's something
that i notice in in general is that
german is a very technical language it's
not it's not ugly to me uh but it's very
technical and uh english is more
uh
i wanna call it an emotional language or
or a fluid language more than more than
german
so i but i but i think that the reason
why
you're you have so much inherent melody
in the way that you talk is because
you're you're
a french canadian
uh maybe yeah i think it comes from that
uh
so yeah friends canadians are definitely
like our french is very sing-songy it's
you know like there's some it's like old
like this old
pre-revolutionary french and so it has a
lot of we have a way more uh yeah we
have way more tonality and than the
parisians do we have more sounds even
than the parisians have in their in
their in their french so i i might look
at uh one of your you started doing
french content as well right
yes yes yeah like uh every two weeks
with uh jp maxwell we're doing some
french podcasts yeah nice yeah uh i
won't be i most likely won't be able to
segment that myself
but but if uh you at one point or maybe
lisa i don't know how well she speaks
french or whoever is
is uh cutting out of that like a
three-minute piece that's that's that's
that has coherence to it i would i would
try to i would try to make a song out of
that just to just yeah that'd be
interesting yeah that means the more you
say it the more that i realize you're
how right you are in terms of tonality
because the the french like we have up
and down in our
in our sound so so like the french will
go up and stop and then we'll go up and
down in our in our in our tone so it's
like a a french from france for a house
we'll say
meson and then we'll say may zone like
i'm exaggerating but it's like it goes
i'm exaggerating a lot for french
canadians might hear this but it will go
like up and down and like that so it's
more it's it has more uh
yeah yeah i never thought about that
interesting
yeah it's um
do you
because you say for most of us there'll
always be foreign elements uh monsters
hiding in our garments of skin um that's
that that kind of ties into the idea of
theosis right
because we're being transformed by by
the holy spirit in our lives and trying
to become more holy
um and and grow closer to god
is there like do people do do people
finish that in their lives or is it is
it always something that christ finishes
when you enter or before you enter
paradise
i mean some some saints definitely reach
theosis in their earthly lives
there are different examples of that
um
so so it's possible
but i would say not for i would say for
most people it it's not that it's it's
it's kind of can something which
continues
um after your body like after the
resurrection let's say something like
that um and it's also described in sanct
in saint uh like saying gregor of nisa
theosis is not described as something
that you kind of arrive to in a static
way you know it's rather this kind of uh
ongoing
this kind of glory to glory a notion
where there's an indefinite there's like
an infinite glory that you're attaining
and so it's it's non-stop it's like a
it's as if like the pattern is is going
up it's constantly moving up so it's not
um
it's not just like you know this image
of the angel sitting in the cloud where
it's like you've got you've reached and
you're there and you're just kind of
there it's it's more of this this
continuous synergy of ascent that is
that is uh constantly going on
that's very interesting so so so you say
it's continuing even after the
resurrection uh and and after well well
after the apocalypse and after where
we're
technically saints in heaven
oh well that's what that's what at least
that's my take on it like i'm sure
you'll find people who disagree with me
but at least that's my take on what i
get from saint gregory at least um that
it's it's just this kind of
this infinite this can this infinite
ascent into into the life of god so
which also seems more more logical
let's say because it's it's not like god
is finite so if if we if we learn
to be in god and learn more about god
even after all of this stuff is
done it would make sense that it goes on
for forever
yeah
yeah that's at least that's the way that
i that i see it in terms of it's in
terms of saying gregory is especially
because he's my my guide for most of
this
is he your your your patron sync too
no my patron saint is maximus
it's same max with the confessor
yeah that's nice that's actually my
that's actually my my name like that's
my orthodox name is maximus and so but i
don't use it i stopped using it very
soon after my baptism just because
uh like even my bishop kind of just
stopped using it and then i just kind of
happened but recently my bishop when he
gave me communion he came to the spoon
and he said
he said don't you have another name and
i looked at him and i was like yeah it's
maximus so he said so maximus received
the blood and body
so i was like that's awesome so i need
to reappropriate that maybe and start
using it again like you can i'll change
my name on the channel it'll be like
maximus pejo or something
nice yeah i'll i'll incorporate that uh
when we when we make new music
that's kind of cool
but it's definitely like i would say my
my
my patreon is a maximus but
uh saint gregory said ephraim and saint
christopher are obviously the saints
that i'm the closest to and that i feel
the most uh drawn to and most taught by
you could say in different ways saying
that from the syrian yeah definitely he
he wrote him on paradise yes right yeah
yeah but just in general his his
theology and the and the syrian fathers
uh saying isaac this hearing as well
their theology is very is very powerful
because it it it's more non-dual in the
way that i i present it you know like
saint isaac the syrian is the one who
said things like
you know that the hell and the fire in
hell is the love of god
and those types of statements uh you
know so i i you know saint ephraim talks
about the womb of god like the idea that
the the sacred womb out of which the the
the
out of which god kind of
comes out of and so they're they're more
non-dual in the way they describe things
and so it's closer to i feel like they
get the pattern more
uh not more but they just get it they
just present it more succinctly let's
say yeah
i understand what you mean when you when
you focus too much on the the the
duality let's say then you become
agnostic in the end
so yeah no no um i i think that's very
helpful to bring it together again
because it also it is together it's not
like i i the way i understand it it's
not like there's real
there's there's a real um
uh
that sounds dumb but i don't think that
there's a real duality i think that's
more how we perceive it
uh then
you know god is not it's not it's not
it's not different
it's it's it's not cut up that's yeah i
mean the best way the best way to
understand it is that is that duality is
contained in unity but it doesn't have
an autonomous existence and so it's that
so that duality is fine as long as it's
always moving towards unity and
contained in unity you know and so that
that would be the sin the fall would be
something like
perm completely inhabiting duality
you know and that's what that's why it's
the knowledge of good and evil but it
brings you into a world of duality in
which you see that as the highest
as the highest thing you know because
god creates with duality it starts right
away at the beginning god created heaven
and earth there's the first duality
right there in the beginning of
scripture and so so duality is
definitely it's it's mostly the whether
or not you move into unity or whether or
not you see duality as the
the final step like the final step in uh
in the world
yeah i see thank you for for clearing
that up
i'll um
play the next song
yeah go for it next the next clip i i
might have three favorite songs from the
album but this is definitely one one of
them it's cyanocephalus waiting for
crumbs it's the most punky let's say or
a rocky song maybe on the edge of the
church maybe on the edge of the world
[Music]
this one is not a canaanite
but a canaanite
that might seem like a really bad pun
but i assure you
that it will cause modern interpreters
to cry foul in reading
these ancient accounts and will say that
all of this question is just a matter of
bad
transcription
i don't think so
[Music]
i don't think so
all these foreigners in the icon of
pentecost
culminating to the impossible monster
are the surprise cover on the edge of
the church
anticipating maybe waiting for the
crumbs
maybe waiting for the anti-dorans we can
imagine flowing out of the church
so that even those we can barely
recognize as our brothers
can have a foretaste of the kingdom of
heaven
the kingdom of heaven
yeah yeah that was the that was when it
was also in the talk when it was like i
felt like i was moving into tricky
territory where i was going to start to
say things which which would
which would make people feel uneasy when
we're the other
uh but in the end i don't think it did
that but i could i knew that i was
starting to talk that it was getting
into a weird in a weird place let's say
so the punk music makes sense that kind
of this kind of punk vibe makes sense in
that moment for sure
yeah i i can imagine that it's it's it's
when i when i when i go through
the this this bit of the the talk when i
when i when i went through this bit of
the talk when i was um checking if there
was anything i wanted to change and i
also when i when i um adjust the rhythm
of your speech i i speak it myself to
the music and then see
where i should put the words so it's
like i'm rapping with you
[Laughter]
um
and and that's all like when when i when
i then later on thought about this bit
and
and and when went a little further and
and started exploring uh this these um
let's say these sentences or these these
notions
uh
it's very easy to get into a form of
anger um or something like something
like that because peop some people are
so unwilling to to have that be part of
the tradition
uh like the modern the modern historians
for example as you said yeah no no
that's just a misunderstanding of
ancient texans that it's no it's not
yeah because it's like the analogies
play themselves out so perfectly that to
say that this is just a misunderstanding
is completely insane like it's
completely insane and it also
that's one of the like one of the main
strategies that i've been trying to give
to people to help counter the
counter the scholarly way of
interpreting is is has to do with
attention and memory and it's a very
sound argument which is that
mistakes happen all the time and it's
almost like it's weird because it's
almost it's close to like an
evolutionary argument right it's like
there's a mutation
and then that mutation
it continues
and because the mutation continues you
can't discount it
you can't say well that's not what it
was it originally was like no what are
you talking about there so even if you
say it's a mistake it's not a mistake
because it was remembered and it was
transmitted and it grew and the
analogies accumulated around it and so
it was actually inciting it had the
insight into something which was true
you know even if it is just a mistake in
transcription it ended up being a better
insight into what was going on in that
story uh and and you can understand that
all the time these types of
these types of um let's say one of the
things i talk about in is that in as
stories last longer in time they tend to
snap to the pattern like even memory the
law the older the memories you have the
more they tend to to kind of snap to the
pattern because it's like it's a golden
thread
uh that you can follow that kind of
joins you together you join things
together um and so when that happens
that's always when the scholars want to
tell us that no this isn't what
the christians originally thought or
whatever that is
and uh yeah so it's it's just
to me it's that type of argumentation
has become completely irrelevant and
useless and hopefully people can use
that argument sometimes too like people
can take that type of thinking uh to uh
to resist the temptation
that we have to give in to this kind of
uh
iconoclastic uh modern scholarship yeah
that's this idea of um
there is no literal interpretation of
the biblical stories right
uh that's
because it doesn't it doesn't matter if
if if saint christopher was a man with a
dog with with a dog face or if he was a
a giant or if he was just someone who
looked normal but but had this monstrous
way of acting it doesn't
it doesn't we don't like first of all we
don't have access to that and and it
ultimately it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't matter because it's those aren't
just aren't the categories the category
that was used was the appropriate
category it's the it's the best category
for explaining what he is so that we can
understand it later in time
uh and so that was the category used and
it's that it's the same with
acenocephalus xenocephaly in general
which is that it was the best category
to describe the experience of something
so strange
you know that it looks
animalistic to us and so
that's a universal experience any any
tribe any group can have that experience
of something that is so other from
themselves that it looks it's it's
it's connects to animality let's say
and so in that sense it's uh it's still
the best category and just like i argue
even in the
in my text about
the the idea of hippopotamus it's
probably one of the best way of
describing it's like a hippopotamus
means a water horse and so does it mean
that there's a genetic relationship
between the a horse the way we
understand it and hippopotamus that's
stupid that's a stupid way of thinking
and so why do we want to now impose the
same thing
back on the idea of a cenocephalus and
think they were idiots for thinking that
there were height that they were dog
human hybrids uh and so it's like
you know who knows maybe there were i
don't know because there seems like
there's some on the horizon for us now
like it seems like we're gonna have
human dog hybrids at some point so it's
like it's so that you shouldn't
completely discount it either but you
also shouldn't get hung up on that
because that's not the that's not the
point of the that's not the point of the
story so
yeah yeah i totally agree
i mean it's interesting when when we
when we we
one can think and talk about yeah maybe
there even were real dog-headed men and
all that and yeah but but it's it's not
it's not important really it's just it's
it's interesting but not important
it's not it's yeah it's not it's not uh
i mean it's not useful to you
to to kind of go down that route almost
it's the same even with the whole
everything that's related to ufos and to
aliens and all this stuff it's the same
problem which is that people they they
miss the force for the trees they don't
they don't understand
what it means as a as a manifestation in
a story and kind of this social moment
and are hung up on
you know like how did they get here and
what are their spaceships and you know
are they interdimensional beings or are
they interplanetary beings or are they
just projections of our psyche or are
they this or that and like yeah okay
whatever that's fine i mean
whatever but
let's try to first of all understand
what how this fits into a bigger story
and what it actually means that whatever
those beings are
that are poking their noses into the
world
like it doesn't they they're aliens like
they're aliens in the strict sense
they're like the ultimate strange that
is that is coming into reality and so it
actually tells us a little bit about
about where we are in the story when
that starts to happen right so
there again is this unwillingness to to
recognize the christian story like this
whole postmodern notion of there is no
overarching narrative
uh there's no no right or wrong there's
no strange or familiar really
um and aliens are just just the same as
human beings or
the animals that we know anything and
yeah it's um it's it seems to me that
and we i've been talking about that with
with people from my from my parish a few
days ago is that um
we um
but it's hard to talk about this stuff
it's definitely difficult it's not
difficult also because there's a there's
this there's right now a social stigma
of even addressing this question right
there there's a it's like to to even
acknowledge the experience of the
strange
is dangerous it's like dangerous because
people attribute it to
uh like to racism or to some kind of
social pressure but it's a universal
experience right it's like it's not it's
actually not uh it's not one which you
can limit to one people
it's just a universal experience of
strange and if you deny it you're
denying
a very important aspect of what it means
to even recognize any identity of
anything
it's i think to me it's better to talk
about
how we can integrate
the strange properly and how we
integrate the strange improperly
that's much better much better way to
talk about this than just try to deny
the category itself because it's a
you're you're denying and you're denying
what it means to to to be human forever
universally denying it and that's not
that's not a it's not useful because
it'll it ends up coming back secretly it
ends up coming back strangely in like in
kind of unconsciously and pops up in
ways in hypocritical ways that people
don't even notice right they end up
doing it but without noticing they're
doing it and then
it just becomes very very odd
that's funny because like yesterday i
saw a sticker that said um space
invaders against speciesism or something
like that
my goodness that's amazing
like you know that people are there like
you know the people are there but
it's nuts that it's nuts that that even
the trope
that somehow
let's say being suspicious of aliens
like of actual like let's say science
fiction level aliens right like mars
attack like being suspicious mars attack
is a great example of like
of a play a joke on that where it's like
they want to be so
accepting to the aliens that the aliens
just walk all over them and they
basically destroy the world and they're
like oh no we don't wanna we don't wanna
we don't wanna in trouble maybe we
misunderstood them like maybe it's like
no man
that's it's that's nuts that's uh yeah i
i'm not surprised but i'm i find it
hilarious that we that we're there
i i did i did i did remember um
the the thing that i wanted to say
earlier is that yeah
what i what i was talking about with the
people in my parish is that there's this
and and i mentioned it earlier this
unwillingness to notice the christian
pattern and so what science did is it
took everything that christianity says
and all the explanations that
christianity gives and just put it aside
and then say okay it can't be that so it
has to be something else and then they
come up with all these weird uh theories
and and ideas
um yeah
is that i mean am i am i being unfair to
them is that really unwillingness or is
that
it's actually mostly it's actually
mostly uh
it's it's mostly a question of levels is
what it is
it's it's a confusion of levels of
reality it's one of the biggest problems
between a traditional worldview and a
scientific worldview which is that the
the scientific worldview
move towards kind of an analysis of
phenomena rather than the meaning of
phenomena
and ex and seeing the world through
meaning as the alt as the first lens
let's say and wanted to analyze
phenomena and then what they did is they
mistook stories that were talking about
meaning for stories that were talking
about analysis and then they they
decided this has no value
because it's not properly talking about
let's say
analysis of phenomena in a way like to
analyze it and quantify it in a way that
you can reproduce it right that's that's
what science is all right and so
when they see
descriptions that aren't like that they
want to discount them and they're and
the worst part of that is that they're
they're across they were in the 19th
century especially across from
christians
who
who wanted that too who like wanted to
take the traditional stories and make
them into these these silly analytical
quantifiable descriptions
uh and so it's like you so so they are
lost right because that's not what they
are and so they lost that fight and so
now we're still dealing with the
consequence of that uh but i mean it's
kind of petering out and you can see
like people like john vervicky and
jordan peterson and and these kind of
people these people that are looking at
consciousness and the science of
consciousness it's petering out because
they now now that they've reached kind
of the end of the rope of what
materialism can offer they have to
reconsider
you know the problem of meaning and the
problem of description without meaning
is actually impossible and that
scientists all along were functioning
with implicit
categories of meaning that were given to
them uh and but as you kind of push that
and you keep pushing and you push the
meaning stories to the side then things
start to fragment and to crumble and you
realize okay wait wait a minute i i'm in
trouble like if i don't recapture these
this meaning manner of telling of of
describing the world so
so it's not really
the case that science
is
let's say in the wrong place it's it's
more that it it doesn't acknowledge that
it also let's say has to work with
meaning and if we were to incorporate
that again then science also wouldn't
wouldn't let's say cause the problems
that it does now
exactly science wouldn't necessarily be
problematic if
they but it's almost like this is the
trait it's like a secret it's like a
secret of reality which is often to
increase power you actually have to
sacrifice meaning to increase power and
so for cain to become stronger in
physicality he had to move further away
from the garden and this is kind of the
the re this is the reality of it you
know you have to you have to
you have to give up meaning to increase
power and you can see it like uh you
know you could you could you could see
it in all kinds of ways like you could
see that you would get an army and the
bigger the army is right the more
difficult it will be for you to maintain
the centralized
meaning of what you're doing and then
your army the bigger it gets the more
powerful it is but the more danger it is
that it's going to start to break apart
and fragment as it gets bigger like
example alexander right that's what
happened to alexander's uh legacy right
is that it was got so big that once the
the meaning the the let's say the person
holding it together died then it just
broke apart because it was too it was
too powerful and too big so that's a
trade-off that's real and it's but it's
a mystery in the way the world cycles
and the idea is that as you move away
and you move towards the end then
something happens and it gets again it
gets restored or returned
towards the the glory and that's the new
jerusalem is the last example of that
where
all of this movement to the end of the
world gets changed into these glorious
you know walls of of uh of jewels and of
gold to kind of manifest how they're
participating in the in the
glory that's fascinating so marvin thank
you so much for doing this and for all
the work you do like i'm constantly
amazed at what you come up with and i
not only that but i feel very humbled
that that that you're that you're out
there kind of spending the time to to to
make what i'm saying beautiful and to
kind of make it in a way that people can
enjoy and can celebrate and participate
in and so i i feel very humbled and very
fortunate that that you're doing that so
thank you for all the work you do
yeah my pleasure
really thank thank you for for for
allowing me to do that and um giving me
the material because it's
yeah it's it's uh
it's helped me so so so much um to to
move towards this i would have never
thought that it it'd be possible for me
at all
and it yeah it made my life better in so
many ways yeah
thank thank you so much glory to god and
yeah
yeah thank you so everybody go
look in the description we'll have all
the links uh to his different channels
to youtube channel but also to the
different places where you can get his
music we can stream it where you can buy
it and so uh so i wish you the best uh
in in the future and we're looking
forward to seeing what are the next
things you come up with
yeah thank you um also all the best to
you and i'm looking forward to talking
to you again
all right thanks awesome